[Music]
Acer computers hosted their big keynote
event ladies and gentlemen here are some
highlights from the Acer keynote we're
just about to get started here just a
quick note on the free shrimp if we
could keep those to two per person that
would be great please welcome now Acer
president CEO Ron bad
today we've outdone ourselves with the
Acer Aspire
x7 no confetti so anyway it's got a nine
gig hard drive it's got free YouTube
boom built-in one access to AOL you've
got now you've got man you've got now
you've got you've got mail
and we've lengthen the power cord by
almost four inches hook it up
built-in pill cap your medicines always
there that was remember sighs the x7 has
a built-in state-of-the-art cassette
deck with auto reverse
[Applause]
[Music]
what's here something pretty neat align
all new denim carrying cases about acid
wash to appreciate the feedback okay
well that was gonna be our big finish so
I just bring off the entertainment hub
and your mom
yeah get my Acer
you